[Music]
hi my name's Bubba awesome little bubble
of hi I'm dawn also known as mama
alright my name is bondo also known as
Barney boy I love barn also known as the
dad hi my name is Jana we're just a very
competitive family for some reason I was
like let's do a baking challenge I
decided to pick something that we really
make which is chocolate chip cookies and
excited to try them god help us all they
don't come into the kitchen
unless it's to get a plate if there's a
sales any pieces of cardboard or plastic
in it you win surprise me I personally
love chocolate chip cookies but I don't
think I like making them as much least
after today it does not say when that
happens that's the most important part
does look like sugar cookies more if
anything don't look like chocolate chip
cookies with me they're mine
so far see one chocolate chip it tastes
like a cookie it tastes fine to me I'm
gonna try again do the hit okay so -
chocolate chip please
not too bad not too bad at all I like
this city of their cooking I like this
now I've taught me a lot of sugar a lot
of moisture oh I'm gonna give it a 5
whoo give me five kind of I live with
these people and I gotta go sleep and
they might be up and they might be mad I
mean it tastes like a cookie it just
doesn't look like a cookie so I mean 10
as me we love
no that's all you need to know what I'm
doing all of Marsha a bunch of different
recipes and I'll try to come up with my
own kind
this cookie got a lot of stuff going on
with it
it's a it's hard I think handling nuts
in it
I can see some chocolate chips for sure
I like a complex cookie that means to me
that stuff I got a flavor you got tins
to it
oh it has like this weird taste it's
like this it's not becky mo very nutty
and business dr. chips but they're not
just like overpowers everything it's
nice it's not overly sweet I've got the
right balance to it when you get past
the nut it tastes like a really good
chocolate chip cookie it's just that you
have to find a spot where there's not a
lot of walnuts I would probably give
this an 8 hi mr. clay - I give it a 4
it's not bad it's good you give it a 10
it's like an espresso chocolate chip
cookie why did I make that it sounded
interesting like it xx in here I guess
it's gonna be more spread so than
chocolate
ooh there's like a real golden brown on
there like my Browns like the brown act
like a coated chocolate guessing it's
not supposed to turn that round okay
it's our new boil
I like how I can see some of the
chocolate chip like trying when you're
melted on top of the cookie looks like
it's kind of losing this cookie actually
looks like in front of that doesn't mean
it tastes like it smells like buck
popcorn pug butter it's cookie kind of
smells a little like coffee if anything
this is not bad at all yeah
chocolate chocolate it's not bad at all
I like food has a taste to it but at the
moment nothing's like worse than this
one for sure this one's up there you got
up in the morning and you uh made some
coffee and put bark butter any instead
of creamer or something thought what
this tastes like
I hate to say I want to give it a full
minute
I know if it tastes like a cookie it
gonna get intent hey pretend that you
don't need a bad water if everybody's
eating this cookie today I'm sorry I
feel like I should be okay I need some
talk yeah well this is right here I can
do chocolate chunks of my preference I
ain't got no chocolate chunks I'm still
talking to see up in there you know I'm
kind of add some little cleavage the
competition this is like a pancake it
looks like a pancake - don't you feel
like a cookie it smell like cooking
baby's fighting it the memo it's this
West chocolate chip challenge weather
and putting effort into this of this
course cooking partner no chocolate
chips in it but we'll see
what's our tanks
I should have the kitchen I'm really
convinced this is a pancake to give this
person a - it's not a cookie even though
it's tough
hey no chocolate chips in it it tasted
better didn't imitation do kegels I give
it a five eight base ride huh it's
better than up someone so here I make
this one by it's a store Bob cook me I'm
pretty sure they won't be disappointed I
made enough cookies in my lifetime let
them run around making cookies they've
had these cookies before though just
because one of my recipes see now you
can totally connect business you know
your basic chocolate chip cookie like
the ones you will see in a store so I
don't know if someone made this or not
but this is small it's really really
really light - you can't get chocolate
chips like this this is just a store
bought cookie be anonymous
look store-bought it does but you could
taste that was homemade this is
chemically induced machine produced
cooking I know this cookie so my cheated
challenge was homemade Chuck chip cookie
I'm gonna give it a three I saw like 80
or because it's not the one homemade
I'll give this one a nine and only
because I like soft cookies you know if
it works it works
[Music]
[Music]
you